I want to ask you just quickly the film
director Olivia Wilde is a new movie out
which she says is based on you this
insane man this pseudo-intellectual hero
to the in-cell community in cell being
these weirdo loner men uh who are you
know despicable in many ways is that you
are you the intellectual hero to these
people
sure why not you know
um
people have been after me for a long
time by because I've been speaking to
disaffected young men you know what a
terrible thing to do that is
I thought the marginalized were supposed
to have a voice
is making emotional talk about it well
God you know
it's very difficult to understand
how demoralized people are
and certainly many young men are in that
category and you get these casual
insults these these in cells what do
they mean it's like well these men
they're they don't know how to make
themselves attractive to women who are
very picky and good for them women like
be picky that's that's your gift man
demand high standards from your man fair
enough but all these men who are
alienated it's like
they're Lonesome and and and they don't
know what to do and everyone piles abuse
on them you've been so controlled today
and yet in that brief moment you got
very emotional why
something to see
constantly
how many people
are dying for a lack of an encouraging
word
and how easy it is to provide that if
you're careful
you know give credit where credit is to
and to say
you're a net force for good if you want
to be
do you believe you're in that falsely
good
net yes in all the details probably not
you know no one's perfect
so
people make their mistakes as they
stumble uphill
Jordan's been a fascinating interview
thank you very much what is so funny
that we live in a world where every
feminist and their girlfriends to talk
about men do this men need to show more
emotion dude starts crying about how sad
and lonely men are and women like you
[ __ ] loser
see okay
this is what I've always known to be
true since I was a young man all this
talk about feminists are four young men
out
I swear to God I swear to God why would
you need men's rights activists you guys
are seeing it right now I swear to God
wanting to be more vulnerable and seeing
feelings I swear to God y'all y'all
don't really want it no y'all don't
really want it because Tom and Tom no
whenever that happens y'all weaponize
that [ __ ] yeah
Trust
your weaponize that [ __ ]
I already keep on going so what are your
thoughts
in order to understand
certain things
you have to be able to listen
to a lot of things come to my coming to
mind and I don't really know what to
understand we I don't really know where
to begin but I'm gonna say this you have
to be able to understand that you have
to be able to listen
which is not what we're doing right now
and I'm not talking about us I'm talking
about Society in general
it's funny whenever we ask and we we
talk about we always talk about
tolerance we always talk about tolerance
and people need to be tolerant we need
to be tolerant but the people that are
talking to the people that they deem not
tolerant are not being tolerant
themselves so you becoming the thing
that you're pointing your finger at
without even you noticing
you got to be tolerant
I can't tolerate that you shouldn't be
why do we why does he even why does he
even have a platform
so if I want to tackle some [ __ ] that I
don't understand that that is that's
wrong we need to have a discussion about
it
to understand where it's from maybe
there's something in there I don't know
maybe there's something in there
something that we're missing
whenever we talk about burning the witch
you know the era where we used to burn
the witch
that area never really stopped
the type of witch we was burning changed
so see him cry like that I can
understand because it
it's like you see you really those
people that hurt you you really want to
hurt them
so you try to compare them to the worst
thing possible
just to get at them you couldn't get at
them intellectually so you're gonna get
at them with name causes and [ __ ]
and being called like a fascist and this
and that when you're just trying to
comprehend
and in order to comprehend you're going
to have to break some
each comprehend in order to comprehend
and to eat the uh the the omelet of
knowledge you're gonna need to break
those eggshells
and it's going to cause a bunch of
problems and [ __ ] you're gonna have the
courage to break that shell
and in doing all that because you're
just trying to comprehend you're being
called all those kinds of name and stuff
like that I can understand I can
understand sometimes even in my own
Community I I can't sometimes I shut the
[ __ ] up
I showed up about yeah but guys let's
just think about that person kind of has
a point because oh my God you Uncle Tom
you're dissing them
you can't even talk
you can even have a discourse and then I
understand why people don't let you talk
they're hurt they're hurt so they can't
it's all
[ __ ] trauma that's talking
at the same time that I understand that
there's trauma but I also understand
that it's just it's not working you
can't talk to someone like that you
cannot talk with someone that has trauma
like that
leave it alone
at some point you shut down if you keep
on talking because you know you're
trying to do the right thing it's going
to hurt you your big ass armor that you
have
is going to lose its efficiency at some
point so I understand where he's from I
understand why he's crying I understand
all of that and you know we've lost
we've lost this
this this conversation I don't even
think that we ever had it but we lost
this conversation
that we in the society the thing the key
thing to understand each other and the
conversation not to prove a point or to
win an argument
but just to understand each other I can
disagree with you and just still
understand where you're coming from and
just that but we're not there yet
that's what I think what do you think
yeah so I've never really cared for
Jordan Peterson's like politics but I've
always enjoyed a lot of his like
psychological
um psychology related uh lectures and
stuff I watched like a lot of those and
they're very interesting for me he says
I've been there that I thought was
interesting I want to pose the question
to be the inside the king of incels
the marginalized we're supposed to have
a voice and it's weird
but speak on it I don't even the title
involuntary celibate me and like I don't
want this but it is where I'm at they
really do feel helpless now we can argue
that it's of their own decisions you can
argue for some folks it's a choice or
they're making bad decisions you can
make a lot of those arguments but I'm
just telling you what they think in
their own head they think they are a
victim of circumstances and whether you
believe that or not what is true is that
they are suffering now how they manifest
that suffering being in terms of insane
rhetoric against women or whatever it
might be that is not something we should
accept but there should be a certain
level of sympathy for understanding that
these are just tremendously lonely
individuals who are suffering I don't
look at women who are approaching the
age of 40 crying because they can't find
somebody and then think well good I
think that's incredibly sad I think
that's incredibly sad
when you got these moms crying that they
still not need to lean on their parents
in the ages of 40 because like they
haven't made I don't think that's great
don't that's sad
and if people want to work with these
people to help them make better choices
or to help them understand these things
better I'm all for it at the end of the
day irrespective of whether or not their
decisions got them to where they're at
or not what is true okay
is for what's good for a society as a
whole if we can change people's mindset
to some degree if we can make people
make better choices in life that's good
for everyone because guess what this
affected lonely people are not good for
society as a whole lot because those are
the people that you can radicalize those
are the people that you can turn violent
okay people ask me like why Jordan
Peterson became popular and it was
really that one line that everyone
started repeating everywhere remember
that line clean your room clean your
room clean your room before you try to
change the world yes yeah and why did
men gravitate towards that message so
much because there's a lot of
[ __ ] that are going to point
out their fingers while three fingers
are pointed back at them it's because a
lot of men need to be told to take
responsibility for their lives
people ask me like prescriptively what
would you tell young men to do today
should they go to college should they
start their own business like take some
responsibility in life move out get your
own apartment start paying your own
bills get a job start taking care of
your community service start doing [ __ ]
take on a responsibility men need to
hear that because more and more men are
checking out more and more checking out
of schools checking out diplomas
checking out of the dating market and oh
promise you this in 20 years you're
gonna see those big effects I think the
polarization will continue
and I think those who claim to be for
the disenfranchised aren't willing to
admit that young men are the
disenfranchised in a lot a lot of ways
and they don't care to
just the other day
when we talked with Tommy she was like
you know whatever just learning skills I
watched like apparently dudes tell
themselves a lot I was like you know
yeah we we do it way more recently
this happened last week this
conversation
so
they don't know most of them don't care
and they pretend they do because it's
the right thing to say from a PR
standpoint in other policies or the
stuff that they support or even the
rhetoric online indicates that the
amount of women who say like oh yeah I
care I care men are trash right
afterwards oh yes best believe I heard
of that yeah I care about men then why
is it that the pin post on your Twitter
pages men are trash and it's fine it's
fine and it's it's actually fine that
you don't care about everything
it's fine it's fine because you got your
own [ __ ] to worry about
but if you got your own [ __ ] up to where
about and it's fine that you don't care
let other people care and that's the
reason why there's some things like that
they're happening
because some of y'all really don't care
the problem is that
some of y'all don't care and claim that
you do when you really don't I also
think that the term inside like I don't
even know if people know what it means
because I've been called an insult I'm
like I'm on inside when I'm inside a
[ __ ] right now we've been called
everything so so so that oh well you
said that women's standards are too high
that don't mean that don't mean that
well that's that I told you that already
yeah the minute there's a word the
minute that there's a word that [ __ ] is
like the new [ __ ] the new invention
since paprika they [ __ ] sprinkled
that [ __ ] like it was some Jamaican
seasoning like they just sprinkled that
new word or that we've been called
everything in the same sentence
opposites yeah
yes no